That's what we like to see...haha Have this one handy as well....
So Zinc again is an abundant metal but it's a metal that we all need for
life, it's part of enzymes and it's part of of many many biologically mediated processes.
I don't know what else to say about Zinc it's a pretty boring metal.
It really is a boring metal. - Now I understand what my collegue said
thinks bit boring. This isn't always the case and when you combine it with some
other elements, it can get quite frisky, as you'll see in a bit.
- Zinc is a really soft metal, it's sort of  greyish in colour, it reacts very easily with
acids to produce hydrogen. In fact it's the way that people make hydrogen in the lab,
or used to.  Now they usually buy it in cylinders. - Zinc is often found on things
like roofs as well, very very high quality roofing material, very slow to
oxidise. - Zinc is used very widely as a coating on iron. So called galvanizing.
You put a thin layer of Zinc  and the Zinc then corrodes instead of
the Iron, so that it stops the Iron rusting, at least for quite a long time.
You can see it on corrugated iron roofs, metal gates in the countryside and so on.
So this is Diethylzinc, so it's C4H10Zn.  - Zinc is quite important
biologically, and there are all sorts of enzymes in our bodies that use Zinc.
And particularly one called carbonic anhydrase that catalyse
at the reaction of CO2 and water and so without Zinc, none of us could survive.
The delivery of the statement that Zinc is boring were greatly under anticipating
the result of this experiment. Really, you've built it up now. That's what we like to see.
Have this one handy as well. Let's give this a go. - I told you to fix the stuff.
So who says zinc's boring? Shall we do it again? Wow...No I don't think Zinc
is in the least bit boring. I don't think that most elements are interesting,
but Zinc is interesting because it's in the same group as Cadmium and Mercury and
Cadmium and Mercury are both pretty poisonous. But Zinc is
essential to life. If you don't have enough Zinc you can't smell things.
There are all sorts of enzymes in your body and those of other creatures, that won't
work without Zinc. So it's really good. You may be bored about it, but if you
didn't have Zinc, you wouldn't even be able to be bored.
www.periodicvideos.com
. . . . . . . . . . . .
Captions by www.SubPLY.com